مساء الخير التاريخ والجغرافيا والاقتصاد
علو محاكمه في فهم العلاقات الدوليه
وتصرفت الدول ان اردتم مثال واضح هي نقدر
ناخذ الصراع الفرنسي الايطالي على الاراضي
الليبيه والمختلف منذ عده سنوات الحقيقه
لصراع الدولتين على ليبيا سرعه قديم لم
يولد هذا العالم او العام الماضي او بعد
حتى 2011 الصراع بيرجع لا نهايه القرن
التسعطاشر لما البلدين قوتين اوروبيتين
بيتفقوا على المستعمرات الافريقيه
واضطرت ايطاليا من سنه الف وتسعمائه الف
وتسعمائه واثنين
توقع بنوع من التفاهمات والمعاهدات مع
فرنسا
بموجبها تقرب مصالح فرنسا في المغرب في
المقابل ان تطرف باريس لروما الاراضي
الليبيه اللي كانت واقع تحت الولايات وليس
الدوله العثمانيه الضعيفه وبالفعل فتحت
الباب لايطاليا اللي ايطاليا سنه الفين
سنه 1911 وظلت محتله ليه ليه لحتى هزمت في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وخرجت منها كدوله خاسره للحرب ولما خرجت
دخلت فرنسا وبريطانيا الليبيه لتقاسم
النفوذ هناك مره اخرى مع تغير الظروف
الدوليه حصلت ليبيا على استقلالها سنه
واحد وخمسين وخرجت كل القوى الاستعماريه
من ليبيا لكن بقي النفوذ الغربي وتحديدا
النفوذ الايطالي والنفوذ الفرنسي وكل ما
يس يعني اسمعها من الليبيين يدرك هذا
التاثير عمق العلاقه خصوصا العلاقات
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه بين الدولتين دول
بعد مرحله الاستقلال بعد 2011 وتحديدا في
الثلاث سنوات الاخيره تجدد الاهتمام بن
بيه لاكثر من سبب
يتعلق بدر المخاطر وسبب اخر يتعلق ب جلب
المنافع
اما درء المخاطر فهي بالنسبه لهم انه
ليبيا اللي بيعتبروها بحكم موقعها
الجغرافي الشاطئ الافريقي لاوروبا
فهي بتمثل اصبحت تمثل مع انفلات الاوضاع
بعد سقوط القذافي والصراع بين كل الاطراف
على كل الصعد اصبحت تمثل اخطر نقطه عبور
للمهاجرين من افريقيا الفقيره الى اوروبا
الغنيه
وبالتالي لا اصبح كابوس يعني الانفلات
اللي موجود في ليبيا تموز على دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي و اكثر الدول تضررا هي الدول
الاقرب ليبيا وفرنسا وغيرهما
من ناحيه الضر ال ال الاضرار من حيث جلب
المنافع ليبيا كانت وما زالت تمثل كعكه
مغريه جدا لكل الدول الغربيه او الدول
الكبيره لانه ليبيا حتى هذه اللحظه هذه
اللحظه هي صاحبه اكبر احتياطي من البطوله
احتياط مؤكد من البترول في افريقيا
وتقديرات شركه بيبي بتقول انه تم البترول
اللي عند الاحتياط اللي موجوده عند ليبيا
حوالي ثمانيه واربعين من نصف مليار برميل
اه بترول
خلاف كميات كبيره من الغاز الطبيعي
وبالتالي هم مهتمين جدا
بالبترول اللي بين اضف الى كل ده موقع
ليبيا باعتباره بوابه الى منطقه الساحل
اللي فيها كثير جدا من المصالح الاوروبيه
وتحديدا للفرنسيين مصالح في شمال افريقيا
ومنطقه الساحل وتحت منطقه الساحل وان ت
ولو بلحظه تصرفات الفرنسيه ومش من دلوقتي
من زمان متواجدين و متواجدين بكثره وعندهم
يعني في حدود
4500 جندي في منطقه الساحل ام لا او حراسه
لمصالحهم في مناجم الذهب
اليورانيوم اللي موجوده على الحدود
التشاديه اللي بين وفي شمال ما يقدر و
بترول وغاز ومصالح كثيره جدا عندهم في
ليبيا كثيره البلدين الدول اللي بيتصلوا
على النفوس في المائه لاسباب كثيره عندهم
مصلحه مشتركه المصلحه المشتركه في اعاده
الامن والاستقرار
ليس حبا في الليبيين ولكن لانه اذا فضلت
الدوله منفلته تضيف للهجره موجوده اه
وتمثل خطر كبير جدا على الاوروبيه في
الفيلم وسبعطاشر
او حاول يعد البحر المتوسط طلب اللي او او
املا في الوصول الى الشاطئ الاوروبيه مائه
وخمسين الف شخص
المائه وخمسين الف شخص دون الغالبيه
العظمى منهم مرت من الاراضى الليبيه
وفي هذه اللحظه انا بتكلم حضراتكم فيها
فيه اكثر من ستمائه وخمسين الف
شخص حاول يعني مهاجر غير شرعي من بلاد
المختلفه من دول افريقيا المختلفه املا في
الوصول الى اوروبا عبر المنافذ الليبيه
وتحديدا من منطقه الغرب
كل دول متجمعين فى المعسكرات الليبيه
محتجزا هم السلطات الليبيه
وبالتالي هؤلاء اذا لم تنجح ليبيا في
التعامل معهم اما ان يعيثوا الفوضى على
الاراضي الليبيه او يعود الفوضى في
الاتحاد الاوروبي الاثنين البلدين اللي هو
مصالح في استقرار اوروبا استقرار اللي
بقول لحضراتكم لكن المشكله انه كل واحد
بيدور على مصالح الدقيقه او بدور على
مصالحها ومصالح وبتخلي يدعم اطراف مختلفه
متحاربه في ليبيا
عشان اوجز المساله لانها كثيره جدا الوجهه
النظر
ومن فتره مشغوله
انه لما بيجي ال ال المسؤولين الفرنسيين
يشوفوا الخريطه اللي بين ويشوفوا عدد ضخمه
جدا من القبائل عدد كبير جدا من المليشيات
اه اطراف كثيره متنازعه على كل ال يعني
الكل نقاط التماس بيشوفوا انه مش ممكن
الحل في ليبيا الحل الوحيد اللي ممكن يصلح
لليبيا هو قذافي جديد مش باي معنى سلبي
يعني بمعنى انه شخصيه قويه قادره على
اعاده الامن والاستقرار وضم كل هذه
الميليشيات تحت شخص واحد وهما شايفينا
الشخص الواحد انسب شخص هو خليفه خصوصا
يعني وعشان كده هم يدعموا خليفه لكن كمان
في اسباب ظرفيه بتخلي هم يدعموا خليفه
حفتر انه تصادف ان كثير من مصالحهم
المباشره اللي تتعلق بمصالح شركاتهم في
الاراضي اللي تسيطر عليها قوات الجنرال
الخليفه كمان بيشوفوا انه الجنرال خليفه
حفتر هو الاقدر على اعاده الاستقرار الى
الجنوب والجنوب زي ما قلت لحضراتكم يعني
البوابه او المنفذ لمنطقه الساحل الافريقي
المهمه جدا الى الفرنسيين لهذا السبب يدعم
متنسوش انه فرنسا طول الوقت المجهوله
بان الانفلات اللي موجود في ليبيا يعني
الجهاديين
العصابات الاجراميه
والمهربين البشر كل انواع الجريمه لكن على
على على وجه التحديد انه ليبيا
بعد عمليه الانفلات اللي حصلت فيها في
ال اه ادت الى ال ال انطلق منها جماعات
استخدمتها ك اه اراضي انطلاق او شجاعه
جماعات
مشابهه انه هي تثير الفوضى في ما يلي
ومالي مازال تخاض على النفوذ الفرنسي كانت
النتيجه لما هددت المصالح هذه الجماعات
مهدده المصالح الفرنسيه في ملف اضطرت
القوات الفرنسيه للتدخل العسكري في مالكي
2013 نفس ال جمعا تعاملت عمليه في احدى
الشركات ال ال الطاقه في الجزائر والجزائر
حليف فرنسا
ما عندي بتقول تقريبا مناطق النفوس
الفرنسيه والايطاليه في تونس في تشير في
الجزائر في المغرب في مالي في النايجر في
اماكن كثيره جدا تهم بالدول الاوروبيه
بالنسبه للايطاليين عندهم ايضا مصلحه
حضراتكم في الهدوء الاستقرار لكن مصالحهم
تصادف ان هي موجوده في منطقه الغرب سواء
مصالح شركاتها واراء ساعه شركه ايلي
العملاقه المواقع اللي هي وحدها
والاكتشافات قريبه من منطقه الغرب
[موسيقى]
الشريط في الانبوب تذكرين ستين اللي هو خط
الغاز اللي بيمر من الجنوب الليبي وقريبا
من الحدود الغربيه الليبيه مع تونس في
اتجاه
البحر المتوسط وصولا الى جزيره صقليه يعني
الى ايطاليا مؤثر ومهم جدا بالنسبه
للايطاليين بعد مسيطر خليفه حفتر على نقاط
العرب والعبور او التهريب غير الشرعي الى
حد كبير في الشرق اصبح الكثير من الهجرات
التوصل الايطاليه وللاتحاد الاوروبي بتمر
عن طريق الغرب وبالتالي الخطر كان الغرب
بالنسبه ل ايطاليا والمنفعه والمصالح تاتي
كل ليبيا لكن تحديدا من منطقه القرن ولذلك
وجدت ايطاليا نفسها مضطره هي تقيم علاقات
قويه مع الجماعات
والميليشيات والاحزاب والقوى اللي موجوده
في الغرب
ويصعب عليها ان هي
تتحالف او تدعم خليفه حفتر لاكثر من سبب
انه خليفه حفتر ليس محبوبا او مكروه لدى
قوى مؤثره ومهمه بالنسبه للايطاليين في
الغرب وبالتالي اللي هي حال فتح خسارتهم
ثم ان الرجل اصبح حليفه للفرنسيين وهي لا
تستطيع ان هي اه تراهن عليه لهذا السبب
فيه خلاف بين الدولتين في ملفات كثيره
يعني فرنسا عملت مؤتمر باريس ايطاليا عملت
مؤتمر باليرمو
بايطاليا دعت خمسين من القبائل الفريقين
اسبانيا استشارت الحرب دعم كل القوى زياده
دعمها ل خليفه حفتر ولكل الجماعات
المناوئه الاصدقاء روما في الغرب
فالخلافات على كل الصعد حفاظا على مصالح
مصالح البلدين المثير للانتباه او للتفكير
انه المصالح الضيقه جدا للغرب دفعته انه
يتدخل بحماقه في اه ليبيا بعد 2011
واستخدم القوه العسكريه بدعم من بعض الدول
العربيه علشان
اطار ان احنا عاوزين نمنع اه مجزره يقوم
بها معمر القذافي منعه المجزره البنيه
التحتيه
واه اغتاله ال معمر القذافي وده مساله
تحتاج منها حلقه ثانيه ازاى وايه الهدف
لكن في النهايه كان الهدف العام انه
يحصلوا على اكبر جزء من الكيك بعض التخلص
من القذافي وهي يعني يبدؤوا من جديد ياخذ
اكبر عقود اعمار في ليبيا وياخذوا اكبر
عقود في البترول والطاقه يعني يستغلوا
الوضع ويقوم قواعدهم وبالتالي حصلوا على
منافع كبيره وكانت حسبتهم ان المهمه صعبه
لان ليبيا البلد اللي متجانس ودينيا
ومذهبيا
اغلبيه سنيا
مسلمه سنيه مش يكون يعني اه يعني قابل ل ل
تشظي ولل انقسام في الوضع في سوريا
والعراق لكن اكتشفوا ان حسبتهم خاطئه
ويبدو انه ليبيا منقسمه وكل على كل
المستويات يعني الشرق الى الغرب
الاسلاميين ضد العلمانيين الاسلاميين ضد
الاسلاميين قبائل ميليشيات يعني اه مداها
كبيره جدا طيب لما وجدوا القصه بهذا الشكل
او هما عندهم شيء اي استعداد للقدره ولا
الاستعداد للدخول العسكري المباشر املا في
اعاده الاستقرار على طريقه بريطانيا
والولايات المتحده في العراق الفين وثلاثه
فهم
يعني رافعين ايديهم بيحاولوا كل واحد يرضى
مجموعه من القوى على امل انه القوى تتغلب
على خصومها وبالتالي يعود الاستقرار
انا بقول التاثير
للخيال لانه اللي حصل ان السحر انقلب على
الساحر يعني الاطماع الاوروبيه ادت الى
وجود فوضى وانفلات فيليبي او ساهمت في
تعميق الفوضى والان ال الانفلات في ا بين
ما حصل فوضى في ليبيا
الفوضى تصدرت واثرت على الاتحاد الاوروبي
وقد تؤدي الى تفتت وانقسامه لانه
ال الهجرات المتتاليه من من ليبيا ومن
سوريا تحديدا بعد 2011 ادت الى تغير
المزاج العام عند المواطن الاوروبي
واستشعار الخطر وبالتالي ادى الى صعود
احزاب قوميه
يمينيه شعبيه تكلمنا عنها كثير كل شعب
الان من خطر الهجرات
والان من التزام مش قادر يتنصل من القيود
التي تفرضها على الاتحاد الاوروبي فيما
يتعلق بحمايه حدودي من الهجرات مختلفه
النتيجه مع ظهور هذه الاحزاب ظهرت
الخلافات كبيره بين دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
مثال واضح جدا على الخلافات داخل دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي فرنسا وايطاليا اللي
احنا بنتكلم عنه والخلاف وصل الى انه الى
حد ان فرنسا الساحه بت سفرها من روما
الاسبوع الماضي وبعد اتهامات او بعد يعني
اتهامات او شتائم شفتها فرنسا غير مقبوله
فرنسا الى شيء في الشتائم والهجوم
الايطالي غير مقبول سبق ان رئيسها ووصف
الاحزاب القوميه اللي واحد منها بيحكم
ايطاليا بانهما زي الجزاء وانهم خطر عليه
مسؤول الايطالي بالالغام والمرض ورفاقه
انت تدعونا الى قبول الهجرات والمهاجرين
فيما ترفضه ان
الصراع مستمر على اثبات كثيره لكن بينعكس
اكثر ما ب ينعكس على الملف اللي لما
الخلاف يزيد في الاتحاد الاوروبي معناها
انه الصراع بين الدول المختلفه وتحديدا
ايطاليا وفرنسا يزيد في ليبيا لما الصراع
يزيد في ليبيا معناها ان الفوضى تظل
متعمقه في ليبيا بين اطراف مختلفه الاطراف
في كل طرف الى اي دوله تدعم واطراف
اقليميه زي مصر والامارات اللي بيدعموا
خليفه حفتر وتركيا اللي بيدعمه القوى
الموجوده في الغرب يظل ال هذه القوه
عندهاش اي حافز انه هي التصالح ويظل
الصراع في ليبيا يعني طويل الامر نسال
الله السلامه لاشقائنا في ليبيا قبل نختم
حابه اعرض على حضراتكم من نوع من
مقترحاتكم اللي طلبوها مني اللي يصوتوا
عليه ول تختارون باصوات اكثر ان شاء الله
يكون موضوع حلقه القادمه الموضوع الاول ان
الصراع على المضائق والممرات المائيه في
العالم في بحر الصين كان هو باحرازه
الصراع في شرق البحر المتوسط
التغيرات الدستوريه
في مصر
ما يجري في الجزائر بعد اعلان الرئيس
بوتفليقه
نيته للترشح لولايه
اهميه البورصه ودورها في الاقتصاد الاسواق
الناشئه والاموال الساخنه بالخمس مقترحات
انا وضعكم على الكوميونتي اللي يجي عليه
اصوات اكثر ان شاء الله يكون موضوع الحلقه
القادمه اشكركم والى لقاء اخر باذن الله
[موسيقى]